taiwanese soldiers fire artillery shells
at a target representing advancing enemy
forces
the democratically self-ruled island is
conducting military exercises to prepare
for a potential assault by chinese
forces they follow repeated incursions
by chinese warplanes into the island's
air defense zone
taiwanese leader sai inguin seen here
watching army reservist train last week
says the war in ukraine proves taiwan
needs to be prepared to resist threats
from china
in a sign of increasing tensions between
the two countries reservists have been
mobilized for 14 days this year rather
than the usual seven
i think the training is very solid we
are now familiar with the nearby
defensive terrain and also places we can
use to fend off an attack i think this
14-day reservist call-up is very useful
[Music]
china considers taiwan a breakaway
province and has previously threatened
to seize the island by force
the leadership in beijing has been
angered by recent reports of taiwan
finalizing its latest deal to buy
military equipment from the united
states
we firmly oppose the sale of arms by us
to taiwan we oppose any official
exchanges between the u.s and taiwan the
democratic progressive party authorities
have repeatedly used the hard-earned
money of taiwan's taxpayers to buy u.s
arms in an attempt to seek independence
by force but they will not succeed
in taiwan's capital taipei they've been
demonstrating in support of ukraine's
resistance to the russian invasion
and four thousand boxes of medicine food
and blankets have been collected for
ukrainian refugees
it's unbelievable this is happening we
should do what we can to help the
children are innocent their lives have
been turned upside down so suddenly as a
parent i feel so heartbroken i want to
help
taiwan regularly holds drills to prepare
for a potential chinese invasion as the
war in ukraine rages on 23 million
taiwanese are hoping the status quo
where they are will be maintained
victoria gatenbee al jazeera